what is the status of that accord being
ratified before the presidential
elections in November well first of all
you cord had a big step forward on earth
day when 170 countries signed the accord
now the various countries including the
United States have to go through filing
a set of articles to join we have
committed the President Obama has
committed that we will join along with
many other countries this year we may
not reach the full ratification
threshold this year which requires 55
countries and fifty-five percent of the
missions I think will be close if not
there and probably next year we will we
will see the the Accord come into force
it's a big driver it's a big deal
frankly I think the the Paris agreement
and the response by 170 countries means
that the clean energy Direction is
really inevitable and that's why we have
to emphasize innovation so that we can
stay at the head of the train and take
advantage of what is going to be a
multitrillion-dollar market of clean
energy technology deployment across the
world